let's go to Hashem al-bara who is live
for us in kalaman marash in Turkey a
Hashem we know the government is under
lot of pressure to help people affected
by these earthquakes what are people
there saying to you are they getting the
help they need
this is a life punctuated for thousands
and thousands of people here by fear of
aftershocks by concerns by growing
anxiety by the need to find a temporary
shelter and then asking questions about
what's next for them just let me give
you an idea about what's happening here
in Karama rash I can see many and many
people coming here to recover their
belongings because they know that it's
just a matter of few days before the
rubble here is going to be cleared
Paving the way for huge construction
sites the government says that it's
adamant on the need to start rebuilding
any time soon they are also saying that
they are offering compensation for hosts
who are going to accommodate people who
were affected by the earthquake he will
also offer compensations for those who
lost their loved ones with a promise
that in about
a year from now they will have new homes
now people are yet to uh to to to apply
for for that uh compensation scheme and
assistance by the government but the
government is saying that this is
starting to happen now and it's just a
matter of time with time before it
trickens down to all those affected
across the vast territory there has been
affected by the earthquake over the last
few weeks
and you you touched on reconstruction is
that something that authorities are
looking at already or I mean look at
looking at what's behind you is that too
early the mountain of rubble that still
needs to be cleared up
but you know Malian because we're ahead
of Elections which are going to take
place in in June this has become a one
of the key political issues now in
Turkey reconstruction the government
says that it will lay down foundations
in March start delivering homes within
one year and that those homes are going
to be safer stronger and better for
those who are affected the opposition
the experts seismologists are saying
it's not a wise decision to start
building now they say instead what we
want is a government implementing
seismic construction codes on one hand
and at the same time we want the
government to take some time when still
we have those after after shocks before
we decide how to move forward they want
the government to put forward a new law
new regulations that will ensure that
those cities that were affected and
those that have or face the threat of
potential earthquakes in the the future
I've knew have new Urban plannings that
can withstand powerful earthquakes in
the future and save lives and this
explains yesterday for example when
President was in adjavan he asked people
for forgiveness for the slow response of
the government in the first 24 hours
right after the earthquakes because he
understands that there's uh at this time
that there's growing concern about the
government response and this is why you
see government officials time and time
again saying we did our best this was a
massive earthquake we're doing our best
we'll continue to do our best and while
we're going to offer people in the near
future is going to be something
unprecedented very strong homes and a
better benefit urban planning for the
people of Turkey
I'm good to talk to you how's there for
us in kalaman marash in Turkey a